und wir schauen in die Ukraine dort hat
das neue Jahr so angefangen wie das alte
zu Ende gingen mit heftigen Angriffen
und zwar auf beiden Seiten unter anderem
sollen bei dem Beschuss eines Quartiers
russischer Soldaten viele dieser
Soldaten getötet worden sein Tim Kröger
ist für uns in der Ukraine in rivene Tim
welche Informationen hast du zu diesem
Vorfall
also es gab ganz offenbar schon am
Neujahrstag einen Angriff in der Region
ferson das hat der generalstaat der
Ukraine erst heute bestätigt er spricht
dabei von 500 Verletzten und toten eine
Zahl die wir natürlich so nicht
bestätigen können aber dieser Angriff
mit dieser hohen
Opferzahl offenbar hohen Opferzahl ist
bisher nicht der einzige es wurde
gestern schon bekannt dass es auch in
der Region dann jetzt einen Angriff auf
russische Truppen gab da spricht hier
von 400 Toten ähm die ukrainische Seite
hat 63 bestätigt das zeigt schon wie
vorsichtig wie wir mit diesen Zahlen
sein müssen aber dennoch wenn sich
bestätigt dass durch diese wenigen
Angriffe in so kurzer Zeit dutzende wenn
ich da hunderte russische Soldaten
gestorben sind dann sind das mit die
heftigsten Verluste die die russische
Seite seit Kriegsbeginn zu verzeichnen
hat und wir hören jetzt auch schon aus
Russland aus Moskau dass sie Kritik in
der Kriegsführung aufgrund dieser
Angriffe bereits zunimmt da wird
beispielsweise da gibt es Gerüchte dass
in der Nähe der Soldaten dieser
russischen Soldaten
Munition gelagert worden war die dann
durch diese Angriffe detoniert ist also
das alles wirft kein gutes Licht auf die
russische Militärführung in Moskau und
es liegt natürlich auch auf der Hand
dass solche Angriffe von ukraisinischer
Seite auf russische Truppen in den
besetzten Gebieten die Moral dieser
Truppen wenn es denn dann wirklich
hunderte Tote womöglich gegeben hat
nicht gerade stark sondern ganz im
Gegenteil weiterhin schlecht denn die
gilt ja ohnehin nicht als besonders gut
auf der anderen Seite gab es in diesen
ersten zwei Tagen des neuen Jahres auch
wieder Angriffswellen der Russen
bedrohnen wie ist da die Lage heute
also es ist ruhiger in der vergangenen
Nacht gewesen nachdem er in den ersten
beiden Tagen nach dem Jahreswechsel des
viele viele Angriffe vor allem durch
Drohnen Gegebenheit viele dieser Drohnen
wurden abgefangen aber die
abstürzenden Trümmerteile haben dann
eben doch zu heftigen Schäden geführt
wie gesagt die vergangenen Nacht war
ruhiger die Menschen hier in der Ukraine
konnten mal etwas durchatmen aber es ist
natürlich die große Frage was passiert
in den nächsten Tagen und da hat der
Präsident
selenski der ukrainische Präsident
gesagt dass er mit weiteren Drohnen
Wellen rechnet offenbar hat die
ukraineische Regierung auch in dieser
Hinsicht Informationen dass wir da um
eine vermöbungstaktik die die russische
Seite anwendet um eben den Widerstand
der Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer zu
brechen und wenn sich diese
Informationen bestätigen dann sieht es
so aus dass die nächsten Tage und Wochen
durch diese Angriffswellen womöglich
weiterhin unruhig bleiben Eindrücke und
Einordnung von dem Krüger live für uns
aus der Ukraine vielen Dank